*bruit de porte* Hop ! Hop ! Hop ! Comment ça va, aujourd'hui on va visiter mon petit studio !
*bruit de porte* Hop ! Tu peut pas rentrer, toi.
*bruit de pognée de porte* Bah t'a mis du temps à comprend la blague dit donc !
Bienvenue dans ce premier espace climatisé *reniflement DEGEULASSE*
C'est là où je tourne toutes mes vidéos.
Par contre, John, tu as payé la taxe ? Tu pénètres dans mon bureau, donc tu dois mettre une pièce.
*Il tape sur la boîte* C'est quoi ça ?
*John* C'est une poubelle ?
*Squeezie* C'EST UNE TIRELIRE ! P*TAIN !
C'est une fente, c'est pour mettre une cause pour m'aider  Met la pièce !
Putain ! IL S'FOUT D'MA GUEULE! (x2)
Je suis entrain de m'étouffer dans le sac en plastique, t'appelle l'ambulance, John?
"1 000 Pesos" ...
T'es allé en Colombie récemment, John?
TU M'A VOLÉ ! *il le dit deux fois*
REVIENT-LA !
On est donc dans mon bureau !
BIEN-VE-NUE !
Voilà.
Allez, on passe à autre chose *il le dit doucement*
Ici, que-ce-que c'est ? (x2)
C'est un capteur d'HTC Vive
Pour quand on fait des vidéos d'HTC Vive !
Il y en autre juste là, tu peux filmer, c'est extrêmement rare hein !
On a ici un casque Overwatch !
À jack.
Apparemment, chaque minute passé à jouer à Overwatch avec le casque Overwatch te rend plus fort
sur le jeu. C'est ce qu'on m'a dit en l’achetant, c'est hyper faux parce que je joue comme une grosse merde.
Ici on a un trépied *"euh" de quelque secondes*
De basse qualité, ne l'achetez pas.
Un retour, le Ninja Blade de chez Atomos, qui marche 1 fois sur 10 avec mon appareil qui est un Sony Alpha 7S.
Est-ce que ces références intéressent des gens?
Bon. OH MON DIEU ! Le set up Razer qui brille de partout. J'adore, je suis un kikoo hein.
ça, c'est mon troisième bras, tu vois? ça offre une certaine liberté de mouvement
Tu peux faire ça toi avec ton, avec ton troisième bras ?
Si t'as un bras nul. "Oh non zut alors" *son qui s'éloigne de plus en plus*
On ne m'entend plus, hein (x 3)
Là, je t'explique.
"Oh non zut alors mais pourquoi il fait ça mais il est con Mais t'as vu, John?
Ici, on a une carte son externe, la focus ride 2I2 4BZ8
Relié à un ampli. apparement un DBX Professionnal Product
Qui permet quand je crie de compresser le son. Pour pas que ça sature et que ça vous défonce les oreilles
Tu me suis, John?
ça, John, tu vois? C'est les meilleures plaques isolentes d'Europe.
Ah non pardon ça, c'est la partie où l'enculé d'ouvrier n'a pas terminé de les poser à temps.
Ici, on a la meilleure mousse d'Europe
Si je vous cris et que je passe derrière tu ne m'entendra plus
*Crie* passe derrière -> plus de son *
C'est quand même pas un truc de.*Passe derrière -> plus de son*
Tu vois ça? Je ne l'ai non pas acheté pour réaliser la vidéo avec Yann.
Où on a créé un véritable tube, hein?
J'avais un petit délire avec la musique.
Et j'ai lancé un logiciel. J'ai fait une note et puis j'ai plus jamais retouché à ce clavier.
Jusqu'à ce que Yann vienne touner cette vidéo avec moi
Euh Donc je le fais gagner. Voilà. Mettez un pouce vert, abonnez-vous et dite autour de vous que vous adorez ma chaîne YouTube
OK ! On passe à la suite
Bienvenu(e) dans le salon de thé
Dans lequelle, il ya une machine à café et pas une machine à thé
D'ailleurs, j'ai plus de capsules depuis 600 années
Petit coin pour acceuillir les amis,
Alors ça, si je puis me permettre, c'est le côté bio. J'ai voulu la joué so 2016, so Nicolas Hulot
Donc j'ai acheté des petites plantes, de la verdure. C'est des fausses
Qui plus très écolo puisque c'est du plastique.
Et j'ai acheté ces pots de fleur pour quoi? Parce que, John, je suis un grand fan de kaplas
ça te fais penser à quoi?
John : Des Kaplas
Eh OUI !! Je peux faire des constructions
Voilà
Je te présente Alpha Béta 08
Je l'ai acheté pour quoi? Parce que quand je dis le mot FDP
Il tue le FDP le plus proche
*bruit de tir mitraillette* John? John? .. Putain, j'ai toujours que c'était un FDP
Ici, nous avons le plus grand rival de notre bouddha préféré
"Bonjour, je suis Bouddha. T'es dans ta jalousie, je suis sur un paravent
Merci à tous"
Et ici, qu'est-ce qu'on a ? On a un deuxième poste
Pourquoi, un deuxième poste, John? Pour que je puisse jouer pendant que mon clone esclave travaille
- Hein, petit enculé
- Tu m'as parlé
- Ta gueule!
ça John, c'est hyper important. C'est le signal de détresse
Tu vois des fois, les abonnés, le week-end, y'a pas de vidéos. Ils ont besoins de leur dose de vidéo
Ils viennent ici, ils mettent ça vers le haut comme ça et ils allument
ça te fais penser à quoi, John?
- John : à Batman ..
- Squeezie : Ouais
John : Sauf que y'a pas de logo là
ça coûtait trop cher
Tu vois ce qui est beau sur... Avec YouTube, c'est ce partage, ce lien
Allumer cette lumière. Pour me montrer à travers la lumière
que je leur apporte un petit peu de particules positives grâce aux vidéos. Tu comprends?
John : Ouais, c'est une allégorie
Nan, c'est un oxymore. Non c'est un ...
Alors est-ce que je t'ai parlé de cette plante ?
Tu te demandes ce qu'il y a derrière cette porte?
Bas un local ménage
Mais tu sais ce qu'il y a dans ce local ménage, John?
Y'a mon trophée entre deux petits coups d'aspi
Il est là !!
Je pense à lui
Il me donne du courage tu sais ?
Je m'interdis de le porter plus de 20 secondes par jour
Parce-qu'après il paraît qu'on prend la grosse tête
Ici c'est un p'tit frigo parce que quand une vidéo a bidé
Je me console comme je peux...
*Musique au piano*
Tu veux que je te dise ce que c'est ?
C'est le piment le plus fort du monde
C'est un cadeau de Mamytwink
Bah bizarrement il est encore là...
C'était y a 2 ans qu'il me l'a offert.
Et SURTOUT, *bruit de claquement de porte*
J't'en ai pas parlé,
C'que j'aime plus que tout dans la vie c'est les flèchettes.
*Bruit d'une flèche qui touche la cible*
Tu crois que c'est truqué c'est ça ? Détrompe-toi.
*bruit d'un coup de pied donné à une flèche suivi d'un bruit d'une flèche qui touche un jeu de flèches* (compliqué à décrire...)
Et ouais mon pote !
Avant de clore cette vidéo, j'aimerais montrer un truc que j'ai montré à très peu de gens,
Cette statuette.
Au couleurs de YouTube...
C'était en 2016, YouTube avait sorti une loi visant à supprimer les vidéos des gens qui étaient vulgaires.
*Pfff appuyé*
Du coup on a dû mener une vraie révolution...
On avait même un petit slogan :
"La liberté ou la mort"
Certains YouTubers ont choisi la mort...
Tu peux voir la tête de Cyprien dans ce seau.
On s'en est sorti, on a gagné mais c'est... c'était un rude combat...
*Petit scène sans paroles... Pour vous faire chialer*
Pffff..... Allez tu dégages John !
Hep hep !
La pièce !
OH ! T'ES MORT ! T'ES MORT !
Abonnez-vous à Squeezie, ou la lampe reviendras !